a big part of the Christmas spirit is to
see the world with innocent eyes of
wonder and that's lesson is number one
New York Times kids bestseller by Fox
and Friends co-host Ainsley Earhardt
through your eyes I love this book my
child's gift to me we welcome her now
from New York and now Ainsley we're so
proud of you thank you so much and as we
all know this is the time of year to
take stock of who's been naughty and
who's been nice so we understand you've
brought your list okay so I brought my
Christmas list I would say on the
naughty lesson I think you would agree
with me Lara would be the media many
people complain that the mainstream
media doesn't report the stories on this
administration fairly so I just think
many of these folks that claim to be
journalists they wake up every morning
and they think I have an agenda to bash
the president and the administration and
I refuse to put out any positive stories
about him now granted there are some
stories that that might warrant their
coverage but there are many that do that
don't make it on their air and I just
don't think many of them are objective
or fair or balanced and they're just not
they're not staying they're not staying
on point and not being focused and I am
90 percent of the stories are negative I
guess but you're just much nicer than I
am saying they're just naughty
yeah I'd say but maybe they nasty nasty
or nice we've come up with our new list
okay what about nice nice nice they want
to talk about exactly exactly so I would
say the military you know if you think
about especially with North Korea we
have men and women that are missing
Christmas with their children this
holiday season because they're fighting
to defend our freedom so that we can you
know we can we can live our lives and we
don't have to worry about a terrorist
blowing up a cafe where that's not the
case unfortunately in other countries so
I'm very proud to be an American and I'm
so grateful for our military men and
women that that don't get the credit
that they need and I'm so grateful and
that reminds me you know this because
you've mentioned my book I really
appreciate that Dan Rooney I had the
pleasure of really getting to know him
over the last year and his family and he
has served our country and he was coming
back from a tour in Iraq and the pilot
came over the loudspeaker and said
please take your seats stay in your
seats while we remove
Cass get off this plane he looked out
the window there was a flag draped
casket being wheeled over to a family
and a young woman was there with her son
and he thought who's gonna teach that
little boy to play baseball who's gonna
put him through college and he decided
he was going to be the one since then
his organization has raised millions of
dollars to put kids through college and
Laurie came on our show and he surprised
me and he said Ainsley because you're
from South Carolina because you've given
money to folds of Honor I presented him
with a cheque because of our viewers who
are amazing that bought the book and he
said because you gave us $50,000 ten
kids are going to go to college he went
down the list he said I picked out kids
that are on the list we have a long list
of people that are that want this
college money because they've lost their
parents who have served our great great
country and but he went on the list and
found people from South Carolina my home
state and put together a video so god
bless him Oh Fanta what a great story
what a great Christmas story Ainsley
merry Christmas to you and Hayley